good evening ladies and gentlemen and
all our configurations will being my
name is Wilfer worth hashing tonight I
bring you the interview of all
interviews my triumph ever returned a
hard-hitting girl I'd like to welcome my
special guest had a security at Freddy
fazbear's pizza fungi welcome hello sir
hello yes greetings my main man hello
hey hey hey hello hello hey howdy
greetings Bonjour yes well could you
briefly explain what it is you do a
Freddy fazbear visa
sorry about that ladies and gentlemen we
have some technical difficulties but
everything seems to be hunky-dory now Oh
fungi welcome well hi there so give us a
brief description of what one would be
doing if given the opportunity to work
in your village well one would be in
charge of viewing security cameras and
at one point would be in charge of using
telekinetic powers to wind up a music
box so the scary pop-up man doesn't go
boo go boo
why that sounds absolutely frightful
what other creepy goings-on happen
around a Freddy fazbear well the lights
flicker quite often there are grotesque
children's drawings posted all around
the office and occasionally you have to
put on a mask so the mechanical
children's animatronics don't forcibly
stuff you into an exoskeleton or or jump
out and go boom you seem to be strongly
inferring the amount of boobs that occur
within your division yes there are a lot
of boobs how many boobs a lot of boos
and if you were to count them each shift
anywhere from two to five boos oh god
man I have no idea how you go about
dealing with that many fool me what no I
I said you close some doors and turn on
and off some lights oh I see well it's
come to my attention that there are some
strange conspiracy surrounding your
restaurant
I want to bloody hell now [ __ ]
oh it looks like I'll have to get things
up and running yet because my crew is
fat around like you give someone one
thing to do and the whole show is put in
jeopardy who goes there
need I remind you that I am Wilfer walk
back now Wharfside don't take no [ __ ]
from nobody